dans mon répertoire je mettais toujours
une ou deux de ses chansons parfois 3
mais plutôt une ou deux si bien que j'ai
enregistré une 2 6 2
une de ses oeuvres qui s'intitule j'ai
vécu que j'ai repris en reggae à ma
manière avec ma couleur avec mon style
avec ma culture et j'ai eu l'occasion
d'interpréter plusieurs fois mais un
jour je les rencontre et haïti et il
savait que j'interprétais cette chanson
parce qu'il était en tournée et moi même
j'y étais pour unis l'été pour un
spectacle et moi j'étais aussi pour un
spectacle mais la semaine d'après mais
je suis arrivé une semaine avant et
sept-îles le même producteur qui nous
avait engagé c'était monsieur rené
marini s'appelle rené marine et
propriétaire de l'hôtel choukoud les
deux cabanes soukouna l'époque qui était
très réputé il y avait des artistes et
des et beaucoup de musiciens d'orchestre
qui passait chez lui donc il me l'a
présentée et je lui ai demandé
l'autorisation d'enregistrer cette
chanson est gentiment il a accepté et
pour moi c'est un grand souvenir je suis
très très contente d'avoir rencontré cet
homme qui est d'une simplicité qui a
apporté beaucoup à la musique qui est
français vraiment travers effectivement
ses textes et sa manière de chanter une
à imiter personne il a copié personnes
et en même temps
à chaque fois nous permettait de voyager
de faire un voyage
quant à travers ses chansons et puis il
a apporté aussi qu'un peu une fraîcheur
parce que il a été l'un des premiers
sinon le premier à porter des des
chemisiers d'hommes rose sur celle roses
jaunes les îles et les chemises et en
couleurs alors je sais que nous avons
perdu un monument